bonsoir vous êtes là pour parler de
votre film j'ai donne en fait vu de ma
vie aujourd'hui
alors ça s'appelle jeunes racailles
c'est un film en costumes ça se passe au
bras gauche tuez vous lire pour on est
habillé voilà où que c'est la banque à
l'époque comme l'assassin c'est alain
delon j'ai bien va-t-on pas à oui oui
oui c'est pas le même jeu trompait cech
c'était dans un coquet tu avais 15
salles là vous êtes rhdp de direction
leur rapporte sérieusement sérieuse
sérieux pas donc de vieilles canailles
c'est le premier film de gérard
jourd'hui qui était qui le producteur et
le grand complice d'eddy mitchell et à
la dernière séance
alors c'est le récit des tristes aux
exploits d'un artisan graveur qui joue
les faux monnayeurs à ses heures perdues
je vous pose tout juste de voir un très
court extrait je suis fier d'eux je vous
en prie septième art je t'en prie dieu
mon chat voilà
ce que j'ai gardé pendant des nuits j'ai
acheté des centaines de salles prix au
détail pour blanchir tout ce pognon que
je change de tronche du fois par mois et
que ma loge
et dans les chemins de tout ça donc une
petite conne de photos dans les rangs 30
secondes voilà alors c'est tiré d'un
roman noir qui s'appelle meurtre en
filigramme de féric brawn c'est un film
très très noir très cynique et surtout
ce qui m'a bien plu totalisé il est noir
il est cynique de la marina oui mais le
but c'est quand même le divertissement
oui finalement finalement c'est à dire
c'est un polar comique oui non si oui
oui et non parce que ça peut faire peur
de freiner assez sinistre sous je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de films qu'on regarde
comme ça au premier degré et le plus
avare au théâtre aux siens sur la
perçoit les gens ont pas on perd un peu
du second degré ya une lecture bon il ya
l'anecdote et à l'histoire
et puis il faut savoir comment on s'est
raconté comment ces jouets et alors on
s'aperçoit que finalement c'est un
divertissement absolument quand on se
trompe pas de salle comme moi voilà vous
avez fait une erreur ça vous arrive
jamais non alors c'est un capture
d'aigrefins comme on disait il ya
quelques siècles on va les cités tout de
même par ils sont tous parfaits pierre
richard anna galiena et jean pierre
bouvier et vous même alors alors les
pires cros pied des quelqu'un vous
embête il passe de vie à trépas doit
tout de suite d'une machinerie qui est
implacable si tôt il ya quelque chose
qui me qui m'ennuie je supprime mais je
crois que ce que je pourrais vous dire
de qui me semble moins très intéressant
c'est c'est d'avoir réuni ses comédiens
là par exemple les richards que je
connais comme tout le monde n'a jamais
j'ai jamais l'occasion il m'a souvent
demandé de tourner avec lui et c'est là
programme que je joue avec lui et on
s'est très bien entendu mais je trouve
que c'est à chaque fois pour un comédien
de rencontrer quelqu'un qu'on connaît
pas qu'on connaît à l'écran mais que je
trouve que c'est une c'est une
découverte et c'est un enrichissement
quand je parle de lui je parle de notre
vedette féminine bana oui et puis de
bouvier de tous ces gens là qui était
vraiment mais tout ça aussi grâce à la
halle à la pâte
et puis la direction du metteur en scène
un bon parce qu'il ya dans tous les
films
et tant mieux il
il ya un maître d'oeuvre ont sont par
moments vous fait vraiment plaisir il ya
un moment une imitation de gorbatchev
volpone et là on sent vraiment que vous
faites l'acteur c'est le grand plaisir
oui mais alors c'est rigolo parce que
souvent on dit ça aux acteurs le dit par
exemple je vais jouer cet après-midi les
narguer nous voir alors oui et qui est
venu me voir et me dit vous êtes amusé
ce soir jeudi mais à quel moment vous
avez ri en scène mais je dis mais sec ne
guérit à ce moment là et vous me dites
aussi la même chose nous dit vous avez
l'air de vous amuser dans le film mais
c'est le personnage qu'ils abusent et
loire le pas on va pas rappeler de vieux
reng magnifique souvenir de la cage et
souvent nous disait à tous les deux
agents et à moi mais dites donc est ce
que vous vous amusez en scène mais
c'étaient les personnages bah alors je
crois que là ya une petite confusion
mais finalement c'est pas une critique
je crois que non mais pas du tout mais
vous vous dites alors maintenant je
pense cette fois guère le nom on n'a pas
besoin de le dire mais viser une terreur
tout ça est pardonnable on va pas
menacer une confuse et est allé
constater c'est que c'est encore la
demeure
oui ça ne va pas et après de meubles
pour manger un peu comme un avant bien
thaler je vous remercie donc un maillot
c'est fini parce que des sacs et même
dix minutes que vous désirez oui je
rappelle vieilles canailles viennent
depuis sur nos écrans depuis mercredi et
qui est un véritable chez de réaliser du
cinéma français un plus cher brice et il
faut y aller parce que je crois qu'il
est bien bien en place devant les
billets pas devant j'allais dire
derrière les deux les deux grands films
américains parce que on est obligé en
france 2 passe est aujourd'hui à 1
derrière les américains enfin au cinéma
comme ailleurs mais enfin ça n'a pas
d'importance mais comme le film français
il est à la bonne place merci beaucoup
et américains oui mais bruno je voulais
vraiment que graphiquement j'adore
michel selon michel ce que je connais
pas beaucoup parce que je
et c'est un professionnel de quoi
revenir ça c'est choquant ghourraf vous
avez fait là tout à l'heure c'était à
mon avis pas admissible je mélange assez
pour la paix tu ne voulais vous voulez
que jouer les barrages de vos pv non
merci
comme je sais qu'il faut pas dépasser
les 1000 francs ou non mais on déborde
beaucoup la voilà c'est 999 francs car
je sais pas ce que le oui oui voilà cinq
ans que je suis ici aussi molle je viens
sydney voilà merci de vos cadeaux il
faut rendre l'antenne à lorsqu'il ya une
émission ce soir il faut pas qu'on
déborde la zone des quarts d'heure je
savais pas qu'on fait payer ont fait
penser jean de réflexion d'ensemble et
bien d'argile et d'eau c'est l'histoire
de deux anciennes vedettes de la
télévision parce qu'on va petit
justement dans l'escroquerie
décidément je rappelle 22h30 par à tata
avec donc nettement vers 23h45
non je ne peux pas le dire dernier
journal en compagnie de rémi roche
demain à 7h50 gérard leclerc recevra à
mon confrère alain duhamel qui parlera
de son dernier livre les peurs française
après le paris dakar et le journal des
courses la nette de la météo de ne
payerez ouais elle va être content
d'avoir deux boselli
dans ce journal nathalie qui parlera
d'un sérieux renforcements des voeux
dans le quart nord-ouest du pays à
demain matin
merci beaucoup pour ce soir